somebody tried to murder my girlfriend
and i
it's disgusting
no we don't got to talk we just no no it
doesn't bother me
uh really at all you know the person i i
i didn't know him
it was like a really strange thing
um you know we were in a parking lot
getting some dinner and
two guys like speed walking
you know walked up on uh tori and i my
girlfriend
and one of them had a gun pointed at
torrey and
didn't ask for money or anything and
started a gunfight you know so and
uh of course i've been doing you know
defensive
tactics and lethal force turned out
really cool
but i'm really sad and depressed already
i forgot the [ __ ] yeah this guy
the dude was like you know really a big
big guy he's probably an
inch taller than me probably outweighed
me by like 80 pounds
he's really excited about uh the
opportunity to
murder both of us that's what kind of i
got the impression from
um and and i
he started shooting at you know tori and
me oh time time time he started shooting
at you
yeah well i i wasn't going to let him
get any closer to
tori so and he had he had the gun out
the whole time
didn't make any demands or anything like
that
and i assume that he was going to uh
engage her for whatever reason
and that's when
stuff started popping off and we got in
a gunfight he shot at tory twice
shot at me six times and uh
you know i shot him the face from 25
yards away
so you do a lot of the defensive tactics
stuffs and train and stuff like that so
how much of that was just like
just training anything it was very
unfair
it was very unfair because you know i'm
i'm as far as i know i'm one of two guys
in the country that can
draw a gun from concealment engage a
target
five yards and put four rounds on target
in under a second so i could draw and
put four rounds on target in under a
second
i do a lot of balance of speed and
accuracy and
very very high level high proficiency
defensive tactics training from
concealed carry with with a pistol so
i'm
really really good with uh with a
handgun my girlfriend tori's got i don't
know 20
world championship titles and
competitive pistol shooting so
we do a lot of that
so for somebody to
[Music]
try and murder us with a handgun in a
parking lot
i don't think that they saw that coming
it was really really unfair for them but
i wasn't going to let them murder my
girlfriend and
myself i was just out trying to have a
hamburger you know yeah
so but uh i honestly
i don't feel one way or the other about
it i wish it never happened but if
it had to happen like we were saying
about talking to god that's be the
question i would ask because
i didn't have any fear i didn't have any
anxiety
you know i wasn't worried i just saw a
problem that needed to be solved
and that's not characteristic yeah
that's
you know in in my mind it's almost
like you know that was a
part of a plan or some some type because
we were in a good part of town you know
wasn't a lot of crime or anything in
that part of town and we're just
having hamburgers somebody's started
shooting at tori and i and
unfortunately for them they picked a
gunfight
with two people that know a whole lot
about gun fights
so now since that whole situation
happened i bet you're training with the
defensive tactics
it's a lot more it's a lot different
when you approach the situation it's
just not training anymore right
yeah it's it it has changed me quite a
bit i've increased my proficiency of the
firearm
more than i ever thought i would i've
been studying
ballistics for nine months
and testing all different types of
ammunition different bullets i had
bullets fail in that particular
exchange and they didn't perform how i
thought they
would have um i thought they'd be able
to solve the problem a little bit
better i through this
exchange i didn't think i'd be i'd have
to fire more than like two rounds to get
this person to stop
shooting um but i had to fire uh
10 rounds which was very very surprising
bullet selection for somebody that's a
concealed carry holder
is super super important and it's not
something a lot of people talk about or
know a lot about
you want something like if somebody's
trying to like in our case
you know somebody's trying to murder you
for whatever reason
you'd want to have the tools and the
fuel in your platform
to solve the problem as quickly as
possible
you know um but yeah i've learned a lot
and it's been kind of a crazy 10 months
thinking about it have you been able to
like package that knowledge up and kind
of like
share it with people as far as like on
the seminar basis point of view type of
thing or what
uh not not quite yet there's still
i i don't want to do that until i know
everything that there is to know you
know so like
for example one thing that nobody thinks
about uh
velocity of a bullet so i had a bullet
that was supposed
supposed to perform very well velocity
wasn't
exceptional it was very slow for a
bullet and
while i was being engaged and she was
being engaged
there was a lot of movement taking place
and at 14 yards
um my bullet didn't get there before
the threat moved out of the way so seven
to ten inches off point of aim point of
impact
at 970 feet per second
yeah i got a little bit better bullets
now my bullets are for concealed carry
and
for some of the people that i've gone to
classes with and helped
thank you well i got
four four different types
what's the best one uh depends on the
application
so ideally like 45 that's too slow
um ideally you'd want something that
can stop somebody that is trying to
attack or murder you or has presenting
lethal force
with uh the knowledge that that
projectile is going to perform inside
of a certain depth of of a threat's
tissue right and not exceed that if if
you're exceeding that not only are you
wasting kinetic energy
but now that projectile has passed
through that person well who's behind
them they might
they might not be somebody that's with
them it might be in a crowded place so
you don't ever want to
accidentally strike somebody that's not
involved an innocent person or something
like that so a lot
goes into bullet design to make sure
that you know police officers
use some uh pretty good stuff but it's
definitely not the best
so i've learned i've done a lot of math
up here as it relates to that [ __ ] no
good [ __ ]
yeah so that shows the specialties you
got the the specialties with the driving
but just as much your specialist with
the drive-in
you are with the firearms and education
that goes along with it yeah you know
it's the same thing
with everything like you know your world
champion your world champion i'm world
champion
if you put that bandwidth into whatever
else
it like baking a cake if you were really
like
[ __ ] up on some [ __ ] like i want to
make the best [ __ ] cake
you know in the world and you dedicated
six months on
like baking that cake your cake would be
bomb right
you know because you know how to get
there because you're already you're both
already you know
world champ multi-time world champions
so it takes that mindset to get
everything figured out
and find every possible avenue to gain
an advantage in performance
so yeah there's a lot to go there's a
lot that goes into it it's been pretty
interesting journey just listening
[Music]
you